joining me now i'm delighted he's with
us matt whitaker former acting attorney
general under president trump matt now
according to cbs there are two parts of
this uh investigation one part concerns
the efforts to swap out electors one by
biden and several battlegrounds another
is examining the actions surrounding
january 6 you know when the supporters
overran the capital
have you seen any evidence matt
that trump could be in any type of
legal jeopardy criminal jeopardy under
these two broad understandings of where
this investigation is going
yeah i have not and i'm glad to be with
you and your introduction in the
monologue was spot on that's exactly
what the left is trying to do here i was
shocked by what mark garland said
essentially leaks were given to the
washington post the day before his
interview and instead of saying i can't
confirm or deny the existence of an
investigation or i can't talk about
ongoing investigations
he gave the left exactly what they are
demanding from him which is essentially
he pretty much confirmed donald trump is
under investigation and we should
rejoice these people are sick and it's
just really um sad to see the department
of justice uh
be taken to this level of political
persecution uh you know they did it in
16
with the russian collusion hoax
you know then congress took over with
the two impeachments and now they're
working together and colluding with
congress and the department of justice
to try to finally uh come up with some
way so that they don't have to oppose
him in 24 if he decides to run
now obama's former solicitor general uh
matt uh neil cuttell had an interesting
read on garland watch
this is the kind of guy you want running
that prosecution an attorney general
who's not bloodthirsty who's cautious
who's incredibly respected both by
republicans and democrats approaching it
like the way a true justice department
prosecutor would in the most sober
careful way
possible
fascinating that's exactly what they
said about robert mueller is it not
yeah it is and i mean neil pretty much
just needs to put on a red nose because
that's exactly what he is
what he's saying and what he's what he's
not saying is that actually garland is
probably one of the most partisan uh
people that could have possibly been
picked for that job because remember the
republicans are the one that held back
his supreme court nomination and i
guarantee you uh that in his mind he
wants to pay back the republicans like
chuck grassley and others that didn't
allow him to sit on the mighty supreme
court and so i you know neil kochol is a
complete leftist everything he says is
in support and admiration of you know
marxist and left-wing ideology and i i
wouldn't you know believe a single word
he says when it comes to
vouching for somebody like merrick
garland
a friend of mine who's not really a big
trump fan uh texted me today saying i'm
basically annoyed about
trump not telling people to come out of
the capitol sooner
but the idea that this
rises to criminal intent to try to like
overthrow the government
it's just i can't believe he said
laughable so donald trump jr was against
the plan
but the president was for some kind of
plan which was has no specifics i mean
the whole thing is just
it's like la la land
it is they're they're again they're
they're looking for any set of facts uh
that they could can prevent you know
again the existence of an investigation
is bad enough if you're a political
candidate uh and so that's what they're
trying to do obviously they hope for a
prosecution uh but ultimately you know
donald trump like he has since he came
down the escalator has fought through
all of these nonsensical attacks
and you know like he often says that you
know they're not after him they're after
the people that he represents and you
know it stands in front of so you know
i'm glad that he's willing to take up
this fight he's right he could uh walk
away and and all this would go away but
he's not going to
well business insider pointed out that
um trump in his tweets they made a big
deal about this avoiding the phrase the
election is over and his tweets where he
accused the vice president of not having
courage to overturn the election
they they're saying that these examples
suggest a certain kind of intentionality
matt for a particular outcome that's
robert weisberg from stanford
is is it tweet a phrase not used in a
tweet
that's now
intent to commit a crime
i i must have gone to a different way
but i must i must have missed that well
in law school
i i i missed it as well and uh you know
to me it's it's really um
interesting that you know the left uh
for
after 2016 in the election they said how
donald trump was illegitimate how he
knew he was illegitimate and you know
this went off for you know he in fact
the president uh sent out a truth that
said uh for 10 minutes showed these
clips and you know if when the shoes on
the other foot they immediately do these
kind of things suggest that somehow not
saying the right words is evidence
as the men's raya for a conspiracy uh to
commit a seditious treason i mean it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's nuts and
it's too bad that we have to talk about
this but i think you know uh people
president trump or even yeah they yeah
they need to know they need to know the
truth
um matt thank you it's great to see you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else